lissa learning is this ability to
subconsciously soak up the the
probabilistic structure of the universe
to put it in a very technical term
basically it's our ability you know
there's constantly patterns going on in
our environment patterns you know you've
seen even social you know social
situations there's constant patterns
with people we're talking to just in
nature there are patterns and and I
found that this ability to
subconsciously implicitly learn these
things without our awareness was court
was related to a very important part of
creativity which is called openness to
experience people who are more open to
their experiences tended to to be do
better on these implicit learning tasks
where they had to subconsciously wear on
the role structure of or wore in the
pattern without their awareness and they
were learning the pattern so intuition
is an important part of the creative
process I don't believe that you know
there's there's this kind of false
dichotomy we've made between rationality
and intuition so again I'm the common
theme today is the middle way right
because you you know you go to a
bookstore you look at different sections
of the bookstore you look at like the
rationality section and it's like
Dawkins and everyone god is dead blah
blah blah and you're like you know
everything you know don't whatever you
do don't grind your intuition intuition
is BS and then you go to like the
spirituality section of the bookstore
and it's like everything's like
intuition intuition intuition rational
people are don't know what they're
talking about they don't really either
not in touch with with them with with
spirituality etc and I think there needs
to be a middle like a section of the
bookstore which says that the optimal
for optimal truth in the universe
optimal not just discovering the truth
but also optimal creativity we need to
listen to our intuition but not be ruled
by our intuition we need to be rational
but we need not be hyper rational and I
think that that that middle way is is
really critical for creativity the Donne
conscious mind computes so many things
outside of our level awareness that are
related to creativity that if we don't
give our subconscious mind the time and
to really reflect into
all the gaps between all these things we
are actually reducing the chances we're
gonna have a great insight great
creativity doesn't come when we're just
solely rationally consciously focusing
on solving a creative problem that's
helpful for solving a non insightful
problem but when we're trying to solve a
an insightful problem with something
that requires a leap you know to come to
an answer we rarely get to that answer
when we're consciously deliberately
focusing on the answer we needed to go
do something else and let the
subconscious mind work and then the will
you feel that intuition what what
William James which is the fringe of
consciousness you know where we we start
to feel bubbling up in our soul that
there's an answer coming you know it's a
very exciting feeling that fringe of
consciousness eventually when it reaches
the threshold of awareness that's what
the aha moment is you know so we can
sort of research as we start to feel
that an aha moment is coming you know
and then when an aha moment comes it's
like it enters pops and conscious pops
into consciousness as one Gestalt as one
whole piece because what our that's what
our subconscious has been doing is
trying to fill in all those little
missing pieces so that finally when it
enters our consciousness we only see it
as one big tooth stalled now that
doesn't mean it's always right however
the feeling that we get of the aha
moment is that feeling of completeness
but it might not be right so we still
have to do the hard work of rationality
to flesh it out